me feel good with my look like this bro
make you feel dumb girl cardi b just
gave fans an inside look at her
refrigerator and the whole thing is
giving off major mtv cribs vibes oh yes
honey yeah remember cribs the early
2000s show on mtv where celebs gave fans
a tour of their house and always showed
off their fully stocked color-coded
immaculate fridge i know i gotta show
you guys the fridge that's just how it
works i know i got to show you what's
inside here you go this is my favorite
flavor and
a lot of liquids juices pickles butter
lots of drinks
not much food i'm just be honest we just
did this like 10 minutes ago
it didn't look like this at all no i did
not redo this just for you guys this is
how it is at all times i'm psycho well
on sunday the 29 year old grammy winner
channeled all that and gave fans a peek
on her insta story make me feel good
with my look like this bro
make you feel dumb good i love when my
face looks
honestly this whole aesthetic is making
me feel good too oh snappity snap snap
goals it's a blessing for god lemonade
apple juice soda lactose free milk
bottled water beer and a whole lot of
condiments but still my neat organized
products in bulk loving heart i got to
see that one more time make me feel good
with my look like this bro
make you feel dumb good i love when my
face looks
of course cardi isn't the only star to
go all mtv cribs on us i don't know how
you're gonna top that back in 2020 kim
kardashian's fridge went viral after she
shared this kitchen tour with fans
refrigerator
where
we keep all of our fresh organic produce
i should note this all started after the
kkw beauty founder posted this snap
causing people to think all she had in
her fridge was a whole lot of milk you
just gotta roll with it but back to that
tour it wasn't just a tour of one fridge
it was a tour of multiple fridges
pantries and freezers kim's kitchen is
basically restaurant grade so you'll
come into my pantry
i have i got rid of all my plastic so
it's all like glass jars of course kim's
sister chloe also showed off her fridge
back in 2015 on youtube
[Music]
so there is a method to the madness when
it comes to placing everything in your
refrigerator and the good american
founder shared her tips to keeping a
perfectly organized pantry i like to
kind of
organize by category like these are all
my crackers or cookies
on this side and also these are the
things that i think i would grab
the fastest which is the junk food but
back to cardi
the up wrapper has been spending a lot
of time in the kitchen lately just last
week she filmed her three-year-old
daughter culture being the cutest little
food influencer hi
kids
look i got rice
and what else corn and last year on an
episode of her facebook watch series
cardi tries she did her best to cook up
some authentic dominican dishes as a nod
to her heritage it's very delicious and
i did it and i like my own food
not only is cardi chef goals she's mom
goals too i love everything about
motherhood back in november the new york
native told e.t that while she had to
leave her kiddos at home to host the
american music awards in la her little
girl was super impressed that she'd be
in the same room as bts my daughter she
she loves bts she's gonna be excited to
see them and bts gave little culture a
special shout out when eg caught up with
them on the red carpet
let's do it again
you know what's up that's the culture
right there let's go
[Music]
you